في بلاد الباسك المخيلة هي الشيء
الشرف بامتياز كاليفورنيا المخيلة
يأتي من ماك
إنه يحشد دونلي هناك إنه الموت
فريق مشينا ولكن أيضا واحد
يمكنه الدفاع عن نفسه dsk يكتب kenneth s i
اسمي ليزا بيرجارا وأنا هنا
الجيل السابع من عائلتي في
يصنعون ماكيلا لكنهم
آدامو سبيس وأحمر الشعر كلافو ستيكس
لذلك في الحقيقة نحن لا نعرف الأصل
الشيء الدقيق هو لغزا
من ناحية أخرى لدينا كتابات لدينا
وثائق أيقونية من
منطقة سارين القرن التاسع عشر و
صادق
مايكل أوين تريد أن تكون عادلاً
سعداء نحن خمسة أشخاص معا
ورشة العمل لذلك هناك بريد إلكتروني
عمل جلدي
ديابي الذي يعمل المعدن بعد ذلك
لديك الكيمياء و frédéric الذي يذهب
اعتني بكل ما هو متقدم
ثم أخيرًا لي يا ليزا
أنا أعتني بجزء النقش
[موسيقى]
لذلك لدينا خطط عقد عقد فيها
زرعها عظيم بلدي
الأب والمشملة هذا هو الخشب الذي
دعونا نعطي maquilas ليس هناك هنا
نحن في العلية
لذلك هذا هو المكان الذي سنقوم فيه بتخزين كل ما لدينا
الخشب الذي ينضج إرادة الخشب
انتظر قبل عشر سنوات
أن يركب لصنع ماكيلا
في عام 2011 تم تسجيلنا في المخزون
مصنوعات من اليونسكو ولكن وفقا ل
من يؤويه قبل المخيلة
إنه كائن سننقله
الأسرة ولذلك فإننا لا نبيعها أبدًا
وهذا أيضًا سبب عدم وجوده لدينا
القديمة في سوق
الفرصة كما أقول لدينا وظيفة
ذاكرة
إنه شيء نزرعه ولكن
أعتقد أن هذا أيضًا شيء
وهو ما لم يقال شيئًا ما
يبدو أننا نحن أيضا هذا
العاطفة التي لدينا والتي أتمنى أن نكونها
تمكن من نقلها إلى الأشخاص الذين
تعال للزيارة
[موسيقى]